I've always thought you have one of the
coolest names of any leading man
Harrison Ford you cannot beat that name
yet you were asked or it was suggested
early in your career that you change
your name who's the true who the
wanted you to change from Harrison Ford
Jerry dekovsky oh well physician heal
thyself
he just had a hatred for his own name
yeah is that true so he wanted you to
change your name yeah he you said
Harrison Ford he went no we can do
better yeah he said that's a two
pretentious a name for a young man
he was about four years older than me he
always called me boy oh boy
[Laughter]
uh-huh so what did you did you come up
with uh an alternate name yeah
Jerry takovsky
well okay I don't think it was very
original I I did I did come back the
next day I was not only supposed to come
back with the name uh uh but I was
supposed to be there uh
earlier than my
naming uh conference to get a haircut
and I'd been given a picture of Elvis
Presley to take with me to the studio
Barber they told you get this haircut
get this haircut and come back with a
name
I said okay I didn't get the haircut
and I said my new name is Kurt affair
incredible yeah that's a great name yeah
is yeah Kurt Affair yeah it's uh it's an
Irish German name
so uh obviously that didn't that didn't
stick
um no nothing did nothing did for a
while no they threw me uh
they let me go after a year and a half
of a seven year contract wow after uh
which I would be making twelve hundred
dollars a week really after seven years
so this is a different time in Show
Business that kind of fascinated me
indentured servitude it really was but
you look at I'm thinking now about the
television you come to Hollywood in 1964
and the big way to get a job if you're
lucky is every show on television is a
western a TV Western pretty much and you
were of American Style
I did Love American Style oh yeah man
I played a hippie oh yeah a real stretch
it's so funny because I my I have a
brother Neil who's obsessed with
TV uh of the 60s and early 70s and so I
told him today
when I'm on the uh
I told him when I was on that's my watch
is it your watch yeah oh that's very
rude it's time for you to go yeah but
you just pushed the alarm on your watch
so you could leave this interview now
and not look rude that's what happened I
don't mind looking rude well that's true
that's true you're right I I just did
misread the situation terribly but so
I'm driving into work today and uh I'm
talking to my brother and I said yeah
I'm going in and talk to Harrison Ford
he said that's so cool ask him about
that gun smoke yeah and uh I said what
no one asks Harrison Ford about his
episode of Gunsmoke he's like oh yeah I
know him and his these other guys take
over the town and you kill a guy in a
bar and uh in a poker game and he knew
it and then of course I looked it up
online there's a picture of you looking
real nasty on Gunsmoke uh yeah I I did
gun smoke in The Virginian but I don't
remember uh that yeah
I did I played the same part twice on
FBI in one season and they didn't even
realize
I just came back and they were like we
had a great time with Kurt Affair what's
your name
no they I I I always played I seemed to
get these if if there were two criminal
Brothers yeah I was the one that was uh
uh sort of duped by my smarter older
brother right right how old is your
brother
um he's three years older than me or two
and a half years yeah see yeah exactly
he tricked me into talking to you and
he'll be delighted because he'll listen
to this and he'll say you got Harrison
Ford to talk about Gunsmoke
um but it is interesting to me like that
whole period because Clint Eastwood get
started in television westerns Burt
Reynolds
um uh you know all these sort of iconic
acts Steve McQueen all these guys had to
do their it's like you had to do your
time on a television Western before you
could move on to other things does that
a fair assessment of that period well no
uh not really
um for Christ's sake you're wrong why
can't you give me that why can't I have
that yeah why can't you just say sure
sure yeah fine Conan let's move on
instead it's no you're wrong
you're you're wrong your brother's wrong
okay I'm okay with him your name's wrong
okay everything's wrong my name's wrong
no
played the same kind of character over
and over again and nobody noticed so I I
don't think it I was not on the I was
not on the Clint Eastwood uh track right
right in television I was on the
here today and gone tomorrow right a
track right right and this is that's why
you're you're making your living
primarily as a carpenter while you're
doing these other parts I'll get a part
and I'm lucky to get this sort of
quasi-background role in these little
parts and I think it's still the case
yeah yeah you're hurting it hasn't gone
well for you I think we can agree on
that look show business has been very
very good to me yes it has yeah I think
you've been good to show business wow I
do I mean you're very uh I was very
lucky uh I mean for for years I uh
you know I did the same old thing I went
from uh Columbia pictures uh to a
contract at Universal yep for 250 a week
um that lasted a year and a half I
always could get out of these things
just by being a dick
really is that how you would get out of
it was just being kind of unpleasant
well in Colombia's case uh uh Jerry
takovski write it down folks
called me into his office and told me
that Mike frankovic who is the head of
the studio was in Europe and he'd
forgotten to sign my contract uh when he
left but he was going to suggest
to Mike frankovich he Jerry takowski was
going to suggest that they dropped me
anyway because I had no future in the
business I appreciate and notice that
you know their name's cold you have
already forgotten mine
uh but no I haven't and what is it
please
um
Conan
O'Brien oh my God I want that on my
that's my outgoing message for the rest
of time
um I'll get a lot of Hang-Ups but uh I
love that when you're in that early part
of your career and this is true of all
of us and someone doesn't see it or
someone wrongs you in some way or
disrespects you you never forget that
name but you're not letting me finish
any story
finally interrupt me every time
I get to that punch line you're there to
wander it
Jerry takovsky said to me that Mike
frankovich hadn't signed my contract so
uh and he was going to
um perhaps like you I got this far
before it was going to suggest that I
that I get that they dropped me he said
that he would give me two uh weeks pay
till uh Mike frankovic came back
um
because he knew that my wife was
pregnant my wife at the time was
pregnant and uh I needed the money
I said no
that's fine
goodbye
and I was out that was it why not just
take the 250 dollars
it was a hundred and fifty dollars two
weeks would have been three hundred
dollars
and
um
that was stupid wasn't it yeah your
wife's expecting a child yeah that money
went a long way back then oh what
were you doing I think there's just how
much money you know now if you kept
exactly that money invested wisely then
would be making 1200 a week yeah
it says here in my research that that's
what you're getting for the latest
Indiana Jones film uh
I have a very clear memory of the first
time I encountered you which is you had
not been on the show yet
and you're easily one of uh my favorite
Hollywood stars and I'm gonna say of all
time and my show is struggling along for
a couple of years and we're getting
we're just sort of starting to catch and
uh I could never get a a star of
Harrison Ford's uh caliber on the
program that would be unimaginable
I'm almost done and
that exhale was like the last breath of
a thousand-year-old man just remembering
that you never asked me
you did not
don't shout at me on my podcast it's
room not shouting
I'm in wa I'm in I'm in Washington DC
for the White House correspondence
dinner and I'm going to be up there on
the Deus with Clinton I've never met
Harrison Ford and I'm on an elevator
door that's closing and all I'm nervous
about how's my set gonna go on this
thing elevator doors are closing and
I've talked about this on the show years
ago elevator doors closing when I hear a
voice say hold the elevator and I'm
thinking I really got to get upstairs
the doors two-thirds closed so I don't
really try to hit the button when the
face
the iconic face of Harrison Ford appears
in between the two closing doors and
looks right at me and the doors shut
and I um all the way up to my room which
is on the eighth floor myself the
whole way up that's what propelled the
elevator yeah the elevator was not
functioning but it was propelled
purely by my it was a horrifying
horrifying moment for me and
um
I apologize again
we recreated the moment on the air you
can see it online where I asked you to
Let's recreate the moment and you gave
this amazing death stare into the camera
and we had two elevator doors close on
it and I re I felt the same trauma all
over again that's how he remembers your
name like Jared
sorry Harrison I could have probably
it was a horrible moment for me and I'm
glad that we've you've come here I I
come here as a friend oh thank you yeah
so it's all past you're not gonna no you
hold you bear no ill will no no
you know Jerry takovsky
that's the nicest thing anybody's ever
said so here's the deal the last time I
saw Jerry takowski was Dallas success
listen in that office on power on power
15 years later I'm sitting in a in the
executive dining room at the executive
dining room
at Warner Brothers
and a waiter came over to me in the
middle of my meal and on a little tray
and there was a little white card on it
I've never seen that before and he
proffered the trade
I picked up the card
it said
Jerry takovsky
vice president blah blah blah whatever
I looked at her
and I looked around the room and
everybody looked like Jerry takowski
and I turned it over and on the back
hand written
was I don't know what it said I missed I
guess
wow he was guessing yeah
yeah I bought I give people credit for
right for acknowledging he acknowledged
that I thought so too yeah I give people
a lot of credit when someone comes up
and says I'm sorry yeah like you coming
here today to apologize for Jerry
takovsky
um didn't quite say he was sorry oh he
just said that he made a Bad Bet which
isn't that's not good enough by the time
I leave here
you will be sorry
laughs
I'm sorry now do these people get to
talk at all I try to discourage it I see
it's working the best I can yeah you
weigh in because you're having the time
of your life I I am really right in into
this Jerry takovsky character Arc
because I do think that there's a night
over into it it is where is he now
exactly okay
let's bring him in well we have a
surprise for you do you have a phone in
number yeah we could no he is here in
person we we arranged all of this he now
cleans pools in Redondo and uh he's here
to say again that he missed his bet yeah
so there you go